هذه وحدة عسكرية تابعة للدولة السورية
تقوم بإعدام
مدنيين غير مسلحين ومعصوبي
الأعين عبر حفرة إعدام ثم حرق أجسادهم
وملء هذه الحفرة
[موسيقى]
لذا
رأيت الكثير من الفظائع التي تم تصويرها
بالكاميرا ولكن هذا الفيلم صدمني على وجه الخصوص
لأن قلة من
الآخرين لديهم الاستعداد الذي يسير به هؤلاء الضحايا نحو موتهم التأكيدات التي تم إعدامهم فيها بشكل واضح قبل وفاتهم]. ما نأمله هو أن يبدأ هذا الفيديو وغيره من مقاطع الفيديو الأخرى التي قد تظهر في
إضفاء بعض الإحساس بالعدالة على
الآلاف من العائلات التي لا تزال
تبحث عن أحبائها الذين ما زالوا
لا يعرفون ما إذا كانوا في سجن
أو في قبر أو يحتمل أن يكون في
حفرة إعدام مثل تلك التي نراها
في هذا
الفيلم الرهيب
[موسيقى] [
موسيقى]
إذا لم تكن جريمة حرب ، فسيكون من
الصعب جدًا فهم ما
يمكن أن يشكل جريمة حرب
[موسيقى]